- HEY, KIDS!
IT'S TIME FOR "VERSUS"!
VERSUS!
THIS WEEK'S COMBATANTS:
THIRD GRADE SOCCER TEAM...
- GREAT KICK, JIMMY!
- THANKS!
- VERSUS...
MONGOLIAN HORDE.
[all screaming]
♪
[angelic music]
[yak bellows]
- BRING IT.
- [blows whistle]
- OH.
[whimsical music]
- [grunts]
[groans]
[all grunting]
- MY FACE!
- [blows whistle]
- YES!
- GOOD TEAMWORK!
[hip-hop music]
- [groans]
- OH, RUNNING MAN,
CLASSIC.
[cuckoo clock chiming]
- [laughs]
- HUH?
- ♪ THE TIME TO BE HAPPY
IS NOW ♪
- [grunts]
- ♪ AND THE PLACE
TO BE HAPPY IS HERE ♪
- [grunts]
- AAH!
- ♪ AND THE WAY TO BE HAPPY
IS TO MAKE SOMEONE HAPPY ♪
- YOU LIKE THAT?
YOU LIKE THAT?
- ♪ AND WE'LL HAVE
A LITTLE HEAVEN RIGHT HERE ♪
- [blows whistle]
- ♪ WE'LL HAVE
A LITTLE HEAVEN RIGHT HERE ♪
- I WANT TO LEAVE!
- ♪ WE'LL HAVE
A LITTLE HEAVEN RIGHT HERE ♪
- [panting]
- WHAT TIME DID YOU
SAY IT WAS?
IT'S THE TIME TO BE HAPPY!
- WINNER:
THIRD GRADE SOCCER TEAM!
[all cheering]
- 'CAUSE YOU CHEAT!
[grunts]
- EVERYONE GETS A TROPHY!